so welcome to my my talk
um
so I'm working as a data scientist at
Blue younger so we develop and run
software for supply chain applications
and of course forecasting is a really
important thing of what we do so we do
build a lot of models and we want to
know are these good models are they
working well and for that we've
developed a method that we call
uncertainty aware model rating in which
we don't pretend to know everything and
that the model can tell you with
certainty what will happen but we manage
the uncertainty so we try to know what
we don't know so we want to go beyond
the description of a model but we want
to provide some uncertainty aware
ratings so what's the difference between
a description and the rating take
something completely different for a
moment the sandwich
and ask is this a healthy sandwich the
first thing that you might do is to look
at the chemical composition of the
sandwich so how many calories are there
how much salt how many fibers saturated
fats and all these things
now to interpret this you either need a
lot of Human Experience or maybe you are
very much into food and nutrition and
you know what all that means or some
education but typically this is not
really answering the question is this a
healthy sandwich
this is why in many places you will find
these ratings on the food so in the EU
we have this Nutri score but it also
exists in other countries that will rate
the nutritional value that will
interpret it and judge it and put it
into a context so this is meant to be
interpreted by a much wider audience
it's a qualitative rating yeah that lay
people should understand like yeah the
salad has an a is good for me and
um yeah the donut has an e and I
shouldn't eat too many of them
now that's the difference between a
description and a rating
but of course we we are not into
nutrition here we are at Pi data so we
are talking about models about
predictions and actuals and also here we
ask the question is this a good model so
the first thing that we do is to compute
the accuracy kpis that that are similar
to a chemical composition like you will
get to mean absolute percentage error a
relative mean absolute error or mean
absolute error that have certain values
um but again to interpret these you need
a lot of Human Experience or maybe
you're into forecasting for the last
five years or so or you have a PhD in
statistics but this is not accessible by
a wide audience so we have developed um
this forecast rating that is
interpretable by laypeople that will
give you a rating between 100 and the
bluish area that means that's a perfect
forecast uh down to zero percent it
tells you this is a horrible forecast
and this is what I would like to present
you today
so what are the use cases in the first
um place you want to compare different
models so you want to model comparison
so maybe you have a Time series model a
machine learning model you want to know
whether the shift in accuracy is just a
very small step or a big step you want
to have it on the scale that tells you
where you are
but also if you are focusing on one
model you want to compare data sets so
assume you you went for the machine
learning model and you want to improve
it
um you want to know should you focus on
the shoes or on the fruit if you're a
retailer you might even want to do some
hybrid comparison so you are already
have the machine learning model live for
the shoes and you and the time series
model for the fruit and you think okay
could you uh maybe switch or so so you
want also to compare in a cross way now
why is this a problem at all I mean why
are people not immediately happy with a
common answer this is because there's
quite a divide between practitioners in
Industries so how things are being done
and statisticians that tell us how
things should be done take for example
the forecast of five t-shirts and the
practitioner will interpret this in an
Ideal deterministic World and say well
forecast the demand of five t-shirts
means five t-shirts will be sold I will
not sell four t-shirts I will not sell
six t-shirts the probability is 100 to
sell five t-shirts the statistician will
interpret this as well on average five
t-shirts will be sold and I will see a
distribution maybe the poisson
distribution that we'll use in this talk
and so on the practitioner wants the
forecast to be ideal or the best
forecast means that the relative mean
absolute error just matches zero so if I
take my prediction I subtract my actual
um I take the absolute value here and if
I think I live in a deterministic world
and have a perfect forecast then zero
should be achievable
the statistic the statistician will say
the best forecast is the sharpest least
uncertain one as long as it is
calibrated so by sharp they mean
um it's a very narrow distribution and
calibration means that the reality
actually behaves like the distribution
predicts now this is not just two
different languages it also leads to
yeah very different practices in
Industry many people use mean absolute
percentage error while statisticians
have been telling us that this is a bad
thing to do for the last 10 years or so
so today I want to present a rating that
uses business relevant metrics but in an
uncertainty aware way so by that I'm
trying to please both I'm trying to
please the
practitioners and the statisticians that
hopefully both say yeah that kind of
makes sense
so we'll build an evaluation procedure
that takes many predictions and many
actuals and will produce some results
some rating which is really qualitative
which will tell you you have a fantastic
model you have an OKAY model or you have
a really bad model
so we need some data to um work on and
I've used the M5 competition data from
kaggle which you can download here and
we're looking at the validation period
in April and May 2016.
so in the first part I will now gauge
the evaluation procedure on the perfect
model so we will start with this result
perfect we will build a perfect model
and then see what this evaluation
procedure should do to really give us
perfect we will then see how to define
the green dark green yellow and so on
areas and apply this on some more
realistic models from the M5 competition
so let's start with fabricating a
perfect prediction and I call this a
post addiction because we we just use
the actuals in Sample
um to build a perfect model we are
applying a method called expectation
maximization under uh the poisson
Assumption and in a way you can think of
it as intelligent cheating I mean we we
know what are the actuals we don't set
all the each individual prediction to
match the actual but we put a little bit
of noise just to make it plausible so
it's it's kind of smart cheating and if
you cut on the different uh postdictions
that we make with this procedure here
you find a
distribution of the sales that matches
really really well the predictive
probability so if I cut on postdiction
close to two I expect to see the red
distribution and I see the blue
distribution same for six and for 10. so
we've built a post-diction a fantastic
perfect model that we know must
um rate as being perfect in this
procedure
so let's evaluate it the first thing
that you would do is you will evaluate
the bias and yeah we we constructed a
perfect model so it's not too surprising
that there is no buys
the next thing that we would do is we
compute the noise and for that we use
the relative mean absolute error for
which we need to take the medium of our
prediction because our prediction is a
poisson prediction and we find this
value here of 41 percent
now if you go with the value 41 of rmae
to your practitioner they would
typically tell you oh that's a lot of
noise isn't that a very poor model let's
break it down by Department let's try to
find out where that noise comes from and
if you do this for three departments um
that we focus on here
you would find these numbers here so
Hobbies 2 has an rme of 76 household one
of 49 and food 3 of 37 so you find quite
different values of rme and if you look
at the mean sales you see that it's
correlated to the velocities of the
selling rate in the Departments so the
bias is still fantastic in these
different departments but somehow the
noise seems to depend on the average
sales but again our prescription that
was built in Sample I mean it's by
definition somehow a perfect model so
where is this coming from
we can also plot it and see okay there's
a clear relation between our velocity
and our relative mean absolute error so
probably I just can't do a direct
comparison but how should I then
um compare this because I still want to
ask the question
um if I had a real model should I invest
my time in Hobbies too in household one
or in fields 3. and for that
um we find that this method is really
really helpful is to bucket all the
predictions and actuals by the
prediction value and we'll use
logarithmically spaced buckets because
this will yeah give you some more or
less equal population in the different
buckets here so between predictions of
0.1 per day to 100 per day and you can
do this quite easily in in Python and
Define a column rounded logarithm of the
prediction and now we just do a group by
this new column here and we will
evaluate everything stratified by these
buckets
so the first thing that we can do is we
can look at the bias per bucket we know
already know there's a very good by or
lack of bias overall there's a very good
lack of bias for each department but we
also see in this plot here that for each
bucket that's defined by its mean
prediction so here we have a bucket of
with predictions around one predictions
around 10 around 100 the mean prediction
divided by the mean sales per bucket is
very close to one so this is where we
want it to be so we are unbiased even in
each bucket of predictions the
predictions of 100 are as unbiased as a
prediction of 0.1
now that's not too surprising it becomes
more interesting if we now look at rmae
in this per bucket View
and now we understand where this overall
means come from because for each
individual bucket the free free
departments perform equally well so
predictions of round one are of the same
quality for food free for hobbies two
and for household one just that for
hobbies I have more predictions that
come from the left hand side from the
slow movers then for food 3 we have more
predictions that are populating the
buttons on the right hand side so if I
do the overall mean it's clear that food
3 has to be more on the right lower
corner while Hobbies 2 is more on the
upper left corner the nice thing is we
can even find uh yeah some semi-analytic
expression for where perfect is in the
space of prediction and relative mean
absolute error and understand where this
comes from because the poisson
distribution is simply more broad for
the slow movers than for the fast movers
so we can Define what is a perfect Model
A Perfect model is one where the
achieved kpis just rely on this best
possible line and the finite relative
mean absolute error has to be rated as
absolutely perfect
now this is not what you will see with a
real model with a real model you will
not touch this line you will be a bit
above
and we can now assume that say for one
prediction bucket like say predictions
around 10 you found some some agreement
with all stakeholders what you still
call a good rating maybe you're here at
a rme or 45 and okay ish rating
um 60 rme
um so you would gain some understanding
of what is a good forecast for one
prediction but the question now arises
how does the scale how does good scale
so do I have to redo all this
um understanding what is good what is
okay and so on for for every bucket I
mean that would be a lot of work and not
not very nice and indeed we can find a
systematic way for the scaling now
scaling of a perfect model is quite
straightforward take the for some
prediction of 10 that has a variance of
10 rme of 25 there's one way to scale it
up to a prediction of 100 and the
variance just scales like the mean
um so yeah it's relatively more narrow
the variance for prediction of 100 it's
also 100 the rme goes down to eight
percent so there's no uh new nothing
unclear here or that we would need to
choose
for an imperfect forecast it's not that
easy because now we have a higher
variance so say this is what we call a
good prediction has a variance of 35 the
rme of 46
um and when when we scale up the
prediction by effect of 10 what happens
to the variance we can in general write
the variance as the poisson part that's
a prediction plus some over dispersion
there's a factor times the prediction
itself to the power of some exponent
so the plus own case the ideal case is
that factor 0 but in general we will
have to live with some overdispersion
here and the question arises what should
that exponent be that exponent could be
linear then we would end up with the
green curve for prediction 100 it could
be quadratic then we end up with this
broad blue prediction here or something
in between like exponent 1.5 but this
would yeah leave us with very different
variances at prediction 100 and were
very different rmaes
so in the prediction per bucket and rmae
panel it's like we have to choose
between these different ways of scaling
and we we already see from the eye that
uh quadratic dispersion is somehow too
pessimistic on the fast sellers I mean
it tells me that for a prediction of
1000 I still have to live with 40
rmae that's that's quite a lot the green
curve here is coming very close to the
black one for the fast mover so this is
one this one's too optimistic
um and it also makes sense if you think
of what these scaling laws would mean
because
um
quadratic scaling means that you assume
that all the systematic errors that you
have in this slow movers will add up
coherently and reinforce each other when
you go to the fast movers linear means
that all these um systematic errors
cancel each other so you have no
systematic errors that Prevail when you
go to the fast movers this is why the
green line comes very close to the black
line so we know that in reality it has
to be something in between parts of the
noise between fast and slow sellers will
be correlated part of it will not be
correlated and already by eye it somehow
makes sense to have this intermediate
case
so we can now Define a rating for the
models like this we know what is the
best possible performance that's the
poisson distribution that's giving us
this blue line here then we Define a
model rating for one prediction for
example 10 and we find an agreement what
is good what is okay and what is
insufficient for prediction of 10 and
then we can scale these reference values
across the board to have this um yeah
this this overall rating
now that we've defined how to rate
models let's apply this on a few models
on the M5 competition we are keeping
this postdiction as a reference we then
use naive one day ahead model where
today's predictions just yesterday's
sales so it's a very simple model we
have a light GBM implementation that
also uses some additional features and a
simple 28 days model that has a weekday
profile but averages in the 28 days mean
per product
so let's see how these models perform
so first of all yeah we start again with
the overall bias and we see that all
models show quite a little bias
um so simple 28 days has a little bit
negative bias the average prediction is
a bit lower than the average sales but
apart from that the bias has no big
difference here and if we go into this
bucket wise representation we see a much
richer picture so here we have again the
mean prediction per bucket on the x-axis
and the mean prediction divided by mean
sales per bucket on the y-axis and I
have put some colors to give you some
visual indication whether something is
very good when you're very close to one
or absolutely unacceptable when you have
a bias that's more than a factor of four
so
um our postdiction here is absolutely
perfect apart from some statistical
limitations so the red bubbles they all
lie nicely very close to one it's not
too surprising the naive one day ahead
model is overall perfectly unbiased but
we see a regression to the mean effect
the
large predictions that come after days
with surprisingly many sales are
typically over predictions so this is
why we are here in the over predicting
range here the small predictions though
so the prediction zero that are shifted
to 0.01 here that's typically an under
prediction because the day on which the
product was not sold that might just
have been bad luck so we see that an
overall bias can still come with a quite
bad bias per prediction bucket the
simple 28 days model improves quite a
lot
um with respect to this naive model so
you see how all these bubbles are pushed
towards the the ideal but the light GBM
model is still better I mean you can
hardly see the blue bubbles here because
they're hidden by the red ones so
they're in the perfect range and only
for the very small predictions we have
some under forecast
and now we can do the same plot but for
rme and we see that the even though the
models don't know about the scaling
property they all respect it so we
actually use the naive one day ahead to
gauge our model so we said if you have
such a such a model that should be rated
as something which will be fair and
insufficient so it's no surprise that
the orange bubbles are between fair and
insufficient but this allows us to make
a very clear separation of the models
here we see the post-diction is perfect
light GBM is in the good range in this
dark green range simple 28 days in the
yellow range and not only is large GBM
better than simple 28 days light GBM is
better for each individual prediction
bucket so it's better all across the
board
um and respecting this scaling property
with exponent 1.5
um now this is uh I really like this
visual representation but sometimes we
need to summarize it into some um
numbers to give an overall rating uh
because you don't have to type the time
to go through these plots and you can
wait each bucket by
um the maximum of total sales or total
prediction in a bucket and then ask okay
is it in the fare range is it in the
insufficient range in the unacceptable
range or so on and make it
um overall mean here and this is what
would come out we would have a noise
rating of close to 100 for our
postdiction it's not very surprising
um the naive one day ahead model is
rated with 41 which is right a mediocre
simple 28 days is in the OK range and
the ygbm is then in the good range
now
um probably you want to then use light
GBM because that's the model the the
best model here and then you want to
improve it so you are asking the
question which department has a
potential for improvement so you you
would redo these plots here now for
different departments so we are doing
the data set comparison and what you
find this is that household one is a bit
better than food 3 for each prediction
bucket here just just not for that one
but for most it's a bit better and this
is also why the noise rating of
household one based on the picture here
is better than the one for Foods 3 so we
see that we're already better and hustle
one then and foot three even though the
rme is telling us a different picture
it's telling us household one has a
higher rme than food 3 but the scaling
awareness tells us the different story
and will tell us well in food 3 you
might be able to improve a little bit
even but household one is already quite
close to the ideal
so when and how should you use
uncertainty where model rating so the
most important application is when you
compare different data sets on the same
model when you ask should I focus on the
shoes should I focus on grocery also
because there you will fall into the
scaling problem so uncertainty awareness
in some way is really a must if you're
on this vertical line here if you
compare models on the same data set and
certainty awareness remains quite
helpful to really understand how is that
model better than the other model
but very much in general I mean don't
judge slow and fast movers together
because slow movers and fast movers are
just different things
um we typically group data into buckets
of similar prediction and evaluate all
those separately and get these pictures
here
um yeah for rating think about what is
the process that you're modeling and
what would be the best model
um how would it perform I mean in retail
the best possible model is often the
poisson distribution in a different
industry it will maybe be a different
distribution but this should Define the
perfect place and then you can select
some simple model to gauge the scale
here just to Define where where does red
begin yeah then compute these business
metrics under the distribution
assumption so to be realistic to
understand like where could you possibly
be with a certain metric yeah and always
consider at least two metrics um bias
and noise alone are insufficient so at
least at least those two and uh maybe
even others yeah I'm happy to continue
the conversation on Talk's discussion
but if there are questions now of course
I'd be happy to to answer them here
so um there is a question interesting
question asked in the in in the channel
it says uh would you be able to
recommend some basic educational
materials for statistics
um yeah maybe maybe you can share a few
few links but definitely I mean just um
so for for retail it's super important
to get some uh impression of how the
profound distribution just looks like
and so negative binomial distributions
personal distribution how they're
related and all these things
um Let me let me look for some some
links and I'll share them in the channel
great
and um
I think that's like the uh all questions
we have on Deck
uh do you have anything else you want to
be like sharing with us throughout this
uh throughout the presentation
oh also one more
how can we estimate the ideal models for
things like ranking from just Steve
saying
yeah so the
you so it's a question like which which
would be the ideal distribution
uh I think what he's trying to ask is
like how would we be able to evaluate
throughout different models
for like let's say you're building a
recommendation system right how would
you be what sort of like model or
starting models you would be using for
that yeah yeah okay for the
recommendation systems yeah then so
maybe I would build a toy system where I
would say that's the very best but still
realistic model that I could possibly
achieve because there will be some
sources of uncertainty that I will never
control so
um yeah so there will be some upper
limit on what I can do
um yeah and using that
maybe as a reference model
um
uh will will be helpful indeed this is
often a difficult question so retail is
easy in that part because uh yeah we
just see that poisson is the best case
uh and it's quite Universal so it's it's
quite well defined
um yeah in other Industries
um you might need to reflect okay what
is what is the process that I'm trying
to model what is my my assumption that I
make
um when I uh when I do my model here and
what what could I possibly expect in the
very best case
gotcha
and um yep I think that's um all
questions we have for now and if you
wish to continue or wrap up a bit
which I have food so so we have some
time left uh yeah technically we have
about like five minutes left so if
there's anything you want to be keep
going through or uh
let me then take the opportunity to to
show one slide that I that I kicked out
um sure because I I insinuated that
there's a divide about
um whether to use our
um maybe or not
so let me let me take sides and divide
so you can you can you see my screen
again
yeah I can add that to a stream yeah I I
insinuated that um yeah there's quite a
controversy is maybe a good
um metric for account forecasts and
um like this uncertainty aware model
rating that I presented I applied it
here to to rme so far but you can also
apply to maybe
um and see what does the best maybe look
like as a function of your prediction so
um maybe is your prediction minus the
actual divided by the actual for each
actual which means that if my actual is
zero I have to remove the data point
because I cannot divide by zero so I'm
removing part of my data which is also
the reason why for very small
predictions I can have very very good
maybes because then my point estimators
and my best guess is just one and since
um the overall probability to sell
something is quite low this best guess
will be very good and this is why the
best maybe goes to zero when I go to the
left then it goes up and then it goes
down again because the poisson
distribution becomes uh small in the
limits of of very large numbers so I
have this very complicated shape here
that makes it very hard to judge okay
you have a maybe value of 30 so what
does it mean
um 30 for this bucket is good 30 for
super slow movers or super fast movers
is pretty bad but it becomes even more
complex when you add these lines that
tell you what is the same quality
because they there's a big asymmetry in
maybe
that for super slow movers noise that
has very little impact it just increases
a little bit of probability to see some
some large outcomes but the relative
error for
um under predictions is uh is is bounded
by 100 because so if you predict zero
the worst absolute percentage error that
you can get is 100 percent
and if you're on the right hand side you
will sometimes over predict but the
worst absolute percentage error that you
get for over predictions is unbounded
and this is why you have this explosion
of maybe for these um yeah moderate
values so yeah if you evaluate maybe and
you get very different values
um and you get values that seem very
dramatic and catastrophic I mean bear
this in mind maybe just behave in a
really odd way and yeah that method is
showing it
um that yeah
a good model can have a 70 maybe for the
mid Movers
well I think we can pick up one last
question from the channel uh from
from a million though I'm not sure if
that's how I pronounce it but the
question is about like wouldn't a base
in approach actually incorporate the
uncertainty by calculating the posterior
distribution of the data
um yeah so the um this expectation
maximization is is very Bayesian so we
we
um yeah try to then get to a prior
distribution for the for the for the
rates
um and
indeed so so far we always did a
bucketing per prediction and you might
ask okay why don't we bucket per outcome
and if you bucket by outcome then you
have to solve all the um question about
what's the prior uh of of the prediction
and uh what is the expected outcome and
there you would you would probably apply
a position methods